Oh Gomer my name is portable fully but
my welcome back Gary
dark penis basically I've been running
around here for a good 25 minutes maybe
hide in there looking at your penis okay
I don't know just seems to be a lot of
[ __ ] puzzles and not that much
[ __ ] stuff going on and that just
makes me kinda aah
so I didn't see this room because this
map is [ __ ] huge but there's supposed
to be a key there oh my god I'm so happy
right now so now we can go through the
kitchen the only problem is I have no
[ __ ] clue where the kitchen is
I could be in space that's how much I
know I didn't even know there was a door
here second ago so yeah it's good times
man good times have you found your penis
yet no look keep looking
oh you're a girl huh give it up get
anyway ah all right
Wickenden moaning I want to sing for you
man I am gonna say don't don't pity your
voice is so angelic
it could tied me good probably even
awakened uh moaning brain amnesia
don't don't pity whoa sorry man nicely
ready for a new scare without you and I
see different barrels now I'm almost
never afraid now but when I think I'll
be okay there are always more Bros hmm I
mean a Misha addo under understand Hey
look at that ass missing let me pee my
girls yeah I'm pump no they don't want
to understand digit sure can try to
touch my peen
you like this video you like this [ __ ] I
called it whoa whoa whoa you see this
you see that you got that on camera D
you got that on camera
all right you know we can make love here
in front of the candle man you like this
you like it I'll be a toasty pic for you
oh yeah you like hot sexy ribs pity you
like that [ __ ]
you like it you can tell me what you
want pay a lot for it to you I'll just
chill out here by the fire the fire [ __ ]
that's what I call it what do I cut cold
so that's good mouth [ __ ] actually it's
kind of cozy
let's sing here by the fire better bye
my love my [ __ ] up button
don't you dare not spin them alright the
kitchen why would someone put a kitchen
down here I don't [ __ ] know piggy
doesn't know battle don't tell me so I
said go I love for the kitchen
whoa Freddie [ __ ] new oh my god whoa
cockroaches on the lens that good yeah
that sounds like your mom's all right
nothing mum a joke right
oh maybe it's over here another locked
door over here black gown but we're not
doing got home you all right please I'll
be trip odometer hodja hodja hodja hodja
hodja hodja hodja hodja hodja hi ah they
change me good [ __ ] barking ah no why
is the kitchen now I don't know these
things
what are you crying for let's try this
door just for funsies cuz I like doors I
don't I know there's a lock on it
alright can't [ __ ] see cuz I don't
have night-vision goggles because
they're not invented yet there we go
so obviously isn't working but what the
[ __ ] is a kitchen
I love you notice but I'm getting
slightly past tiny bit might have
trippin are you who they got this own
way no I dare come on why not why not
why why can I not collect oil if I want
you ah well [ __ ] you then you know not
gonna do it don't list is the kitchen
I'm serious
up back to cheating I mean I'm not gonna
cheat I'm just gonna zip we'll get
something I guess
ah [ __ ] right I gave him the
meditation masturbation no we did not do
that I need some smart guy helping me
like Annie bro I can [ __ ] give me
advice it's not you Jennifer
I have you baby I know you love me I
know you can there's supposed to be a
door here somewhere which is kind of
obvious can't believe I haven't eaten I
get Deo it's this here's where the
[ __ ] kitchen is that makes so much
sense I don't even [ __ ] know where to
begin
alright here we go I mean no no
directions for anything
alright we are in the kitchen up the
thing I uh
the thing about horror games is when you
go too much on one thing and you kind of
forget the horror it's my my
but I don't like like for example in if
there's a game like just [ __ ] fear
for example where you shoot [ __ ] and
that's fun but it still has our elements
in it but then you start focusing too
much and shooting and killing that you
don't focus on being scared I don't know
if that makes sense but it makes it
forget things
at least the [ __ ] am i doing in here so
I think it's a say hey yeh yeh yeh
wait I jump up pretty yeah look at my
friend she's Rudolph Adolf and hit the
what I mean
Randall Gallo all right come nice part
hey mr. shadow you're drinking too much
man
alright what a party here's the acid cuz
everyone else may have acid in the
kitchen [ __ ] I'm watching oh [ __ ] is
is called dad and jackass I don't want
to swear so I think it's perfect the
same but anyway
I was going out [ __ ] barrels
collection and it's the same with puzzle
if you had too many [ __ ] puzzles you
just started focusing on the solving the
[ __ ] puzzle instead of being scared
so I think puzzles are good in our hands
but don't if you it's better if you feel
threatened by trying to solve the puzzle
obviously I feel kind of safe in this
area it's not no [ __ ] [ __ ] is
happening for like the last 45 minutes
that should my take on that [ __ ] I am so
glad as we're leaving this place this
place was a nightmare this our this mod
started off really nice but right now it
feels really drag Mouse really drying
out so like hasn't haven't [ __ ] in so
long all right what the [ __ ] I put the
acid
what do you want from me Hulk smash oh
wait I have a hammer all right shop
habitats whoa whoa yes that's I'm so
happy
oh this feeling this satisfaction of
holding a bone and throwing it a little
bit and then just taking it up and be
like bone I want you inside me
what gotta get away the bone whoa nice
light bone all right ah of course yeah
Ranjan it are Roger did all Roger the
door click the dark suit I could click
it I do it yo yeah oh no he locked me up
didn't he and whenever he does that with
the locking thing with the hands it's
gotta be difficult maybe I was like a
one of those fingers and he can use for
a lot of stuff
I don't know I invent the thing
all right the journey continues
it's what the [ __ ] man what am I I thank
God's I'm sorry oh my please throw me on
the mattress all right
it's locked now to all people I invited
you're the one that's still alive a
little depressed
all right I like it spur my wife is that
you Oh Thomas
God the door is locked think you can
find a way to open it
uh-huh I'm afraid that's not positive as
you trollop
what just do it man yeah Carrie I know
you're not the brightest guy you should
know by night I've so many puzzles I
know you've been reading my notes what
[ __ ] no it was you after all you six
such Wow did you do to my sons to me
calm down yeah we almost I don't even
know that you had friends ah ah whoa
nice penis for him well have it done
with him you bastard I said calm down
calm your Pepsi but I don't know where
Nick is he disappeared shortly after my
plan was set in motion but I do know
is left many survivors no no it's so Eva
why would you yeah exactly
doing all this because it's funny I know
it
why cause it's fun of course we chance
to think about it my own I Oh sir vive
ok no no my creations against a bunch
creations haha I know I [ __ ] jail you
show yourself you coward I don't think
so
if you're lucky we might meet again
after all it wouldn't be enough fun to
kill my test subject so early uh what
what do you mean maybe you will find out
I shall leave you now
alright I feel like a maggot back and
finish something I've been working on
for years it will be my horriffic oh how
[ __ ] my poem alright I can awesome
place I can experiment Oh No what does
it mean by that
I don't know doesn't make any sense it
doesn't your I get out from the Sun ah
fine Nick we shared it hope he's still
alive I don't care alright let's click
this this wall seems weak box spinner
ooh thrower did away Oh what is this
sludgy you have one nice guy in this
game I like you hi John power nice
one-shot kill holy [ __ ] did you see that
flashy your hair just wow dad is not
good for anyone
what's up what's up very good we're good
thank you kind of nice in here I do
enjoy it quite a lot
they have lions like hey lion lion Wow
ah
so lame for a lion okay Oh epic spin the
wheel moment man let's spin it
I'm spinning it how I spun it good
we're spin where do it
wheel of fortune we love meowing hey
this plant all right
whoa all right a poison behind cool
Calcutta
I have daddy's episode here but like
beer if you enjoyed she's got a cobra J
I'll see you next episode opal ever
unmake stay awesome how much how much
how much how I fell under power
it's mine oil man oh man that's how I
roll what happened there all right